et vous Salomez vous rabich Billy
bonjour à vous bonjour bienvenue sur ce
plateau merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes laidante de la
Géorgie un pays qui ne connaît que trop
bien les méthodes de Kremlin oui bonjour
salut mesurabi Julie vous ne les
connaissez en effet que trop bien ces
méthodes du Kremlin comme le disait
Pauline à l'instant parce que votre pays
la Géorgie en a subi en subit toujours
les conséquences on se rappelle
évidemment de la guerre de 2008 la
Georgette a perdu 20% de son terroris de
son territoire avec cette intervention
russe perdue deux régions l'abrasie et
l'ossetti du Sud c'est la quatrième fois
d'ailleurs dans votre histoire que vous
vous connaissez ce genre de choses avec
la Russie c'est un petit peu comme en
Ukraine avec Denis qui se sent menacé
c'est ça le paradoxe alors avant d'en
venir à l'actualité évidemment avec tout
ce qui se passe en Ukraine il y a
aujourd'hui des dizaines de milliers de
soldats russes qui sont présents donc en
abrasie et en eau Séti du Sud vous
n'avez pas la capacité militaire de
reprendre ces territoires on voit bien
que d'une manière générale la communauté
internationale ne reconnaît pas ces
indépendances c'est sécession de ces
deux régions mais en même temps presque
personne n'est prêt à vous aider à les
récupérer est-ce que quelque part poussé
par les faits vous avez un peu renoncé à
ces deux régions où la Géorgie est
renoncera jamais non on n'a pas renoncé
à ces deux régions on a renoncé
formellement à l'usage de la force pour
les récupérer
parce que ce rapport de force tout à
fait inégal ne laisse pas de d'autres
espoirs que éventuellement de d'avoir
une
occupation encore plus importante par la
Russie mais ça ne veut pas dire renoncer
et il y a deux échecs majeurs en tout
cas de la Russie dans dans cette
relation là c'est que effectivement
c'est ces territoires occupés ils sont
occupés personne ne les a reconnu sauf
des clients de Moscou deux ou trois mais
en réalité la communauté internationale
donc n'a pas reconnu et continue à
reconnaître la Géorgie dans ses
frontières
de vous personnellement vous vous sentez
menacé que vous pourriez vous retrouver
dans une situation similaire à celle de
votre homologue ukrainien le président
zelinsky je pense que nous sommes tous
menacés et que le l'Europe a trop
longtemps pensé que la menace russe
c'était pas pour elle et je crois que ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui se sursaut
européen cette unité européenne c'est
probablement le fait de réaliser qu'on
ne peut pas laisser il y a eu d'autres
précédents il y a quelques dizaines
d'années dans le siècle dernier on ne
peut pas laisser un régime totalitaire
dictatorial avancée sans réagir parce
qu'à un moment donné il n'y a pas
d'arrêt et que personne ne sait qui sera
le prochain menacé vous avez Salomé je
vais lire rencontrer hier à l'Elysée le
président Macron il vous a assuré de son
soutien la Géorgie n'est ni membre de
l'OTAN ni membre de l'Union européenne à
ce jour pensez-vous que la France ou
quelqu'un d'autre viendrait à votre
secours Vladimir Poutine avait l'idée de
reprendre là où il s'était arrêté en
2008 ça dépend ce qu'on appelle à votre
secours
on sait que en Ukraine aussi il y a pas
une intervention militaire des pays
européens ni des États-Unis parce que
nous ne sommes pas dans le temps parce
que l'Ukraine n'est pas dans le temps
d'où cette quête de sécurité de la
Géorgie de l'Ukraine de la Moldavie
parce que nous savons que tant qu'on
n'est pas sous la protection de
l'article 5 on n'est pas sous cette
forme de protection en revanche ce que
je suis venu chercher c'est l'attention
c'est le soutien celui qui est manifesté
aujourd'hui envers l'Ukraine et qui est
le pas supplémentaire le pas politique
supplémentaire en direction de l'Union
européenne pour sentir comme l'a dit
ursulaforme des Lionnes que nous sommes
des vôtres et ce soutient là il est très
important il est celui qui est
politiquement décisif et celui qui
attend la population géorgienne la
population
ukrainienne aujourd'hui sous les bombes
c'est cela qui est fond mental
aujourd'hui alors justement vous avez
rencontré Emmanuel Macron hier mais
aujourd'hui vous allez rencontrer à
Bruxelles Charles Michel et Ursula
Anders c'est une sorte d'opération
commando pour que surtout on n'oublie
pas la Géorgie malgré tout ce qui se
passe en Ukraine c'est pas malgré c'est
il est clair que la priorité aujourd'hui
c'est l'Ukraine parce que je ne suis pas
sous les bombes
mais dans cette priorité il est très
important de ne pas faire apparaître des
maillons faibles que Poutine ne puisse
pas se dire bah tiens en Ukraine ça se
passe mal pour moi donc essayons un
endroit qui est plus facile qui serait
la Moldavie ou la Géorgie donc c'est
effectivement revenir sur la carte de
façon très pressante mais c'est aussi
en quelque sorte faire notre déclaration
alors je n'ai pas signé
l'acte de demande d'adhésion comme la
fête publiquement Zelenski et c'est très
très bien il y a aujourd'hui une fenêtre
d'opportunité qui est la prise de
conscience par les Européens que pour
ces pays il faut comme la dire cela leur
ouvrir les bras ça veut dire une autre
forme
d'intégration qui ne soit pas cette
forme technologique technique
progressive de fermer les chapitres
d'accession et peut-être une forme plus
politique peut-être pas immédiate mais
mais pas politique un signal politique
très clair pour tout le monde est-ce que
je force un peu le trait évidemment mais
ce qui n'a pas un peu tout perdu ces
derniers jours Vladimir Poutine on voit
que l'Europe ou en tout cas l'Union
européenne n'a jamais été aussi unie
dans une crise on voit que l'OTAN
finalement sort de son statut de mort
cérébral pour reprendre les mots
employés il n'y a pas si longtemps par
Emmanuel Macron Vladimir Poutine
n'arrive même à pousser à payer comme
l'Allemagne particulièrement hâtif à la
chose militaire à non seulement livrer
des armes létale ce qui est quand même
extrêmement rare chez les Allemands mais
aussi augmenter son budget de l'armée
alors on sait quand on est membre de
l'OTAN il faut rappeler dans tes
spectateurs on doit consacrer 2%
Donald Trump avait largement essayé de
divinir et puis on voit bien que il y a
des sanctions de plus en plus fortes il
y a des ruptures tout niveau culturels
sportives etc est-ce qu'il va atteindre
une sorte de point de non-retour ou il
ne pourra plus finalement
réintégrer entre guillemets le Conseil
des nations comme on dit un peu
facilement en tout cas il a tout faux
c'est à dire qu'il a tout mal calculé
tous ces calculs politiques ou
stratégiques n'ont pas été ce qu'ils
pensaient y compris chez lui je pense
pas qu'il avait imaginé qu'il puisse y
avoir il y a déjà eu des manifestations
à Saint-Pétersbourg qui est toujours
connu comme la ville
plus dissidente en quelque sorte mais
pas dans 25 villes russes le nombre
d'arrestations est un signe que il y a
quelque chose qui se passe aussi dans la
population russe et qui est sans doute
liée au fait que effectivement vis-à-vis
des Ukrainiens ils ont un sentiment de
proximité différent de ce qu'ils avaient
vis-à-vis des tché qu'ils ont massacré
ou vis-à-vis de la Géorgie donc là il y
a un élément supplémentaire et puis il
faut regarder le reste du monde cet
isolement c'est pas seulement vis-à-vis
l'Union européenne c'est pas seulement
vis-à-vis de la Russie même la Chine
ne soutient pas
complètement
et sans scier je dirais cette espèce
d'invasion
humainement inacceptable
Erdogan a pris des mesures en mer Noire
alors que ils sont dans un dialogue
assez proche donc tout ça est à observé
et je pense que non seulement
l'impression que l'on a c'est que
Poutine est très isolée à l'intérieur
c'est lui qui décide et qu'il a pas
beaucoup de conseillers qui l'écoutent
mais il est de plus en plus isolé à
l'extérieur et c'est gestes qui sont
l'isolement y compris dans le domaine
sportif tout ça c'est c'est très
pressant et ça va être très
pris par la population russe elle-même
il y a la population russe on voit qu'il
y a plusieurs milliers d'arrestations
mais
vous parlez du reste du monde et
notamment des Occidentaux est-ce que
finalement on n'a pas un peu laissé
faire pour tin toutes ces dernières
années il y a eu évidemment on parlait
tout à l'heure de votre pays de la
guerre en Géorgie en 2008 mais il y a eu
la Crimée il y a eu évidemment le Dombas
il y a eu tous ces empoisonnements
d'opposants scribal navani l'assassinat
de Boris namsov l'opposant numéro 1 au
Kremlin il y a toujours eu des
condamnations verbales diplomatiques il
y a eu régulièrement des sanctions mais
jamais suffisamment forte pour
l'empêcher d'agir et le dissuader de
continuer est-ce qu'on a une
responsabilité nous européenne nous
occidentaux dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Ukraine mais je pense que
oui dans la mesure où il y a eu pendant
des années non seulement l'absence de
d'union d'unité de fermeté mais il y a
eu de l'apaisement permanent ces mesures
d'apaisement ne pas irriter ne pas
provoquer les mots qu'on entend encore
aujourd'hui par certains dirigeants
politiques ne pas provoquer personne n'a
jamais provoqué Poutine aucun de ses
voisins n'a jamais menacé la Russie
c'est la Russie qui par ses actions
transforment ses voisins qui pourraient
être des voisins normaux et harmonieux
on a rien fait pour le dissuader on a
tout fait pour l'apaiser mais ce ne sont
pas les dirigeants de cette
de ce caractère là ne se laisse pas
apaiser ça ne fait que les encourager en
quelques mots si vous le voulez bien car
le temps nous manque malheureusement
les images de convoi militaire russe qui
avance vers Kiev vous avez eu je crois
le président zevenski au téléphone dans
quel état d'esprit l'avez-vous trouvé et
quel est votre degré d'inquiétude par
rapport à la situation des civils
notamment en Ukraine l'inquiétude elle
est extrême puisque de tout côté on
entend parler de bombe de cluster bomb
je crois que c'est des bombes à sous
munition si je me trompe pas
les attaques sur les immeubles civils
sur les maternités enfin tout ce que
l'on entend
fonde une provocation extrême moi j'ai
trouvé
zellenski tout aussi ferme et tout aussi
déterminé tout en acceptant la
négociation moi ce que je trouve très
important de dire c'est que dans cette
situation c'est lui et lui seul qui doit
décider à quel moment et quelle forme de
compromis il peut accepter les intérêts
Ukrainiens c'est lui qui le représente
il ne faudrait pas que il soit sous
pression d'accepter une
une forme de compromis qui serait au
delà de ce qu'il pense raisonnable pour
les intérêts de son pays donc faisons
lui confiance il a mérité la confiance
de sa population et de ses partenaires
merci beaucoup merci Salomé et d'être
venu ce matin sur le plateau de France
24 présidente de la